so listen man uh i've been a fan of your
work for for a long time so it's uh cool
to actually get to talk with you um i
like throwing some curve balls at the
beginning i promise these are not
hard-hitting if someone has never seen
anything that you've done what's the
first thing you want them to watch
um
movie movie
okay
um is there any reason for that
um well it was the first movie i ever
did first time i ever did anything on
film and uh
and it's a true character piece i mean
it's a comedy um so
i think a lot of people don't realize
that um i got my start as a
in comedy
um i obviously grew up when i was
younger i saw a clash of the titans uh
and i am a big fan of ray harryhausen um
did you ever actually get to hang out
with ray do you have any memories of
working with him
well of course um and he didn't well he
didn't really like me at the end of the
movie because i refused to do a
worldwide tour that
was being underwritten by um
south africa and at the time south
africa was on my list of places i
couldn't go
and he got very angry with me about that
and i didn't speak with ray for 25 years
but then
he called me up one day and said you
know what let's do a tour together and
uh and we went out we we hit a few
places and talked about the movie
together
that i i didn't know any of that and i'm
just going to say thank you for sharing
um
when i was a kid i maybe had watched a
little bit of la la and i'm just curious
when you made that pilot did you have
any idea that the show was gonna go did
you have a good feeling when you were
filming it
oh we had no idea uh you never do with
two tv shows like that but in those days
it was picked up already for like six
episodes or something so we knew we were
going to do at least six
what was your um if you don't mind when
you look back on the making of the show
is there anything that like people would
be surprised to learn about the behind
the scenes like what it was like to make
something like that
well i think um
one of the things is that the writers
would come over and we would from time
to time have coffee and just gab
and they took whatever we talked about
and put it in the show so
um
yeah it was uh
you know the writers absorbed everything
about our lives and if there was
anything in our lives that was
translatable to the show we would find
it in the script the next week
jumping into why i actually get to talk
to you today congrats on the series uh i
watched the whole thing um i think one
of the things that really does so well
is that it captures that energy
after 9 11 when everyone was just so
scared and so nervous about everything
that was going on and nervous that
another terrorist strike could happen um
could you sort of talk about that aspect
of the series
well i mean look you're right we we were
all freaked out by 911 and we thought
that this was an extension of 911 we
thought well okay the terrors are now
they're gonna they're now putting
anthrax and envelopes and sending them
around
and um
it wasn't that we began to realize that
maybe this was more homegrown that it
actually freaked us out a lot more i
mean so we got terrorism coming from
over there and terrorism coming from
here too you know so
um i was very aware of it when it was
happening and even canceled a trip back
east from l.a because it was happening
at that time
and we were all told to go out and buy
duct tape and in case the you know a
crop duster dusted us with anthrax we
could duct tape our windows shut
so yeah it was it was a scary time and i
was we were all in the middle of it
um what was it about these scripts the
story getting to play tom what was it
about the series that said i want to do
this well it was tom brokaw because it
was absolutely terrifying to take on a
role like that and
i like to do things that are
impossible to do for some reason and
some kind of hubris that i have in me so
someone says this is take this on you
you'll never be able to do it like okay
i'll do it you know and uh
um you know i've i've sort of lived my
life that way a lot of things that i've
done or things that most people
wouldn't do i did a movie called making
love back in the early 90s that every
single
movie star in town turned down because
they thought it would hurt their career
and i thought it was a great opportunity
so i did it
it's so interesting i've been fortunate
to over the
over the many years of talking to many
different actors and so many of them
have told me when i'm scared of
something that's the immediately i know
i need to go do it no that's okay there
you go that's exactly who i am yeah
um what i'm curious the
did you watch a lot of video like how
did you find tom's voice to for the for
the role
no this tremendous amount of material on
tom brokaw of course and we have this
thing called the internet so yeah i mean
it's actually pretty easy to go in and
find uh enough material to
to bend yourself closer to another human
being no i've never tried to do that
before i've never tried to done it i've
never done impressions before of people
or anything like that so uh
i'm not um
it's not what i do so i had to relearn a
whole new way of approaching a character
and
which was a challenge but but it was a
fun challenge
well that i was actually i wanted to
know what were you spending because i've
spoken to a lot of actors and they talk
about let me let me put it like this if
you if you have a big scene say on a
monday um how do you typically
how early before that day are you
breaking down
um how you're gonna do it you know like
i've spoken to a lot of actors who talk
about how weeks in advance and other
people are a little closer to the day
i'm just curious about i like learning
how people like to work
well it depends upon how much time we
have with the scene if i have a script a
month in advance or two months in
advance i'll spend every day working on
it before i get to the set you know but
in this day and age a lot of times the
script doesn't get into your inbox until
hours before you're doing the scene um
so if i i'll take as much time as i have
and i will work on it as much as i can
before doing it uh
you know um
preparation is everything and
i used i worked i was fortunate enough
years and years ago to work with george
cucor a great actor a great director and
uh he he's
used to say every day you know that his
friend spencer tracy said the most
important thing about acting on film is
learning your lines you're the three
most important things learn your lines
learning your lives on your line so
i took that to heart
i
always love when i can do an enter any
any interview when someone is bringing
up uh spencer tracy that's fantastic
i'm just throwing that out there um uh
one of the things how much did you
actually know because i knew i knew a
little bit about this but as i was
watching i don't want to do spoilers
i
forgot about oh man how can i word this
without um how much did you know about
the full storyline because as i was
watching i forgot certain things and was
quite surprised at the reveal
um
you know i i didn't know that much about
the full storyline and that's what's
going to be great when people watch the
series is they're going to it's a it's a
mystery you know and it's a it's a
thriller in a way so uh
not only do they learn about that
anthrax attack but you know they also
are on the edge of their seat wondering
okay who done it uh so
it's uh it's great that way
uh i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of shows and movies
i think maybe you figured that out about
me um what do you think might surprise
people to learn about the making of this
series
uh
well i don't know i mean i we we had to
quarantine for 14 days when we got to to
toronto and and i did that and then i
had i had one what i all of my work was
compressed into a few days because i was
in
the uh one the episode one and episode
two and i they were very generous to
compress it all in two days but then
just before i was going to film my last
scene with daniel daniel
[Music]
he got exposed and he had to go into
quarantine immediately so i had to you
know stay there for another 14 days and
so that happened a few times during the
filming of the show
it's a very different thing when you're
filming a show in a pandemic you know
and particularly in a pandemic where the
borders are closed down and there's all
this quarantining that has to go on so
uh i don't i don't know if that would be
surprising to someone or not but uh that
did happen to me
oh i definitely think that's that's uh
something interesting to learn i was i
was thinking when you have to wear that
the the the outfits for for being in
court like uh with the diseases like the
protection gear so probably the first
move first project that people like i
want to wear all that all day like all
the scenes where i'm being protected
this is great i'm sort of joking around
but you know normally i don't think
people want to wear that stuff no i
don't think so
right um so talk a little bit about you
do have a fun scene with daniel though
um when you eventually got to film it um
daniel really brought a lot to this role
having to
you know um react to everything that's
going on but he's also dealing with ptsd
can you sort of talk a little bit about
working with them
well like i said well you know we had
that one scene together and um you know
that
14 days stretched out
because i had to wait for him to be out
of quarantine um so we didn't have a lot
of preparation time together because by
then we had lost 14 days you know they'd
had to move everything around so when i
i had prepared for that scene without
him um and i the first take we did i
came in much hotter than uh the director
wanted it to be now i know they may have
used that tape i don't know what take
they used but um you know i i had you
know
i worked myself up for pretty intensely
uh i was angry um that they were not
paying attention to you know my
assistant who was really sick so i came
in really hot and the director said no
no no he's not that angry whatever so um
but we ended up i think we ended up in
just the right spot
no i thought you did a great job and i
really enjoyed this series um i got a
wrap there i'm just gonna say seriously
thank you for talking with me and i wish
you nothing but the best well and right
back at you